Well.
Good morning.
You'll remember that last time we talked
about dividing tuberculosis into two
major errors in terms of the way that it
was understood and experienced by human
society.
The first era we talked about last time
was what I chose to call the age of
consumption.
At that time only the lungs were known
to be affected by the disease as all
other forms of tuberculosis as it's
now understood where then thought to be
instead different diseases at the time.
The theory of anti contagion aneurysm
that by now is familiar to all of him was
still dominant on the tuberculosis
patient was deemed to be a,
should we say blameless and harmless as
he or she had a disease thought to be
primarily hereditary.
The treatments in fashion,
we're still traditional remedies
of 19th century medicine,
well familiar to you Veena
section or bloodletting.
Poultices were applied and people
were given medications with an aim of
increasing their appetite to combat the
wasting away creosote was administered.
We know it now primarily
as a wood preservative,
but it was in fact in the 19th century,
one of the chief medications used to
treat tuberculosis and it was administered
sometimes internally,
sometimes by inhalation
to relieve the call.
It was applied topically to the lowerings
to ease the coughing and alleviate
ulceration and sometimes there
were submucosal injections.
Sometimes quinine was administered with
the strategy of lowering a patient's
fever and we've talked about gases
that were administered to combat the
infection directly in the lungs.
Sometimes carbolic acid spray opiates
like Louden them were sometimes given to
relieve symptoms and patients were
advised to travel to more salubrity as
climates to visit the sea,
the mountains,
the dry American southwest,
the Mediterranean,
and then we moved on from not period
the age of consumption and saw the
beginning of the age as a,
I'd like to call it this morning,
the age of tuberculosis from around the
1880s and this was marked by a number of
factors that came together
to foster new attitudes,
new treatments,
and new public health strategies
to deal with tuberculosis.
The first, and this man is by
now extremely famous to you.
Uh, and that's Robert Caulk. Once again,
his theory of the germ theory of
disease and the discovery as you know,
of the bacterium.
That's the causative agent
and tuberculosis in 1882
but that wasn't sufficient
to launch what we call
the age of tuberculosis.
In addition,
I would say that it was influenced
by international politics,
a gathering of international tensions,
clashing imperialisms
with colonial expansion.
Remember than that,
this is a time when population growth
was held to be essential to military
strength,
indeed to national survival,
to industrial production
and economic power.
This was the age when Social
Darwinism was at its height.
And in that context,
tuberculosis was held to
be a real national danger.
It was an internal danger.
And because of that,
patients came to lose their glamor.
There were no longer regarded
as creative, spiritual, sexy,
and in no bold,
but were thought to be a danger
to health and to society.
So that was a second,
should we call it the social economic
diplomatic context in which tuberculosis
was situated.
And then there were epidemiological
studies that went along in the period.
Public health became much more cognizant
through statistics of the ravages of
tuberculosis.
There were studies of its transmission
and society and knowledge,
statistically based.
Now we're placed anecdote
and the implication was not,
although tuberculosis did indeed affect
the elites of society and the arts,
it was in fact disproportionately
a disease of the poor,
of the dangerous classes and in
the American context of unsavory,
impoverished immigrants,
a disease of Irish and Italians.
And so tuberculosis slowly becomes
more stigmatized and more shameful.
Well,
the result of all of these converging
factors was from about 1880 to 1940 an age
of tuberculosis,
certainly,
but also a war on tuberculosis with new
strategies of public health to combat
what was seen to be a major
national and international menace.
So let's look at the weapons in the new
war in anti-tuberculosis public health.
The first chronologically was
also the most distinctive.
And in some ways the most
interesting and creative.
And this was the establishment of
Sanatoria or sanitary or if you prefer,
which gave rise to an
international sanatorium movement,
the prototype.
And the world's first TB.
Sanatorium was founded in 1859 but the
movement then slowly gathered momentum
towards the ends of the century and then
continued down to about the 1950s when
antibiotics led to the closing of the
Sanatoria and for a time or you fork view
that tuberculosis was
about to be eradicated.
A view that unfortunately has
turned out not to be the case.
The founding father of the sanitorium
movement was a German Herrmann Bramer.
He was a physician and
fell ill with tuberculosis,
not something at all unusual
and expecting to die.
He traveled to take the cure
in the Himalayas to a surprise,
though he recovered and he attributed
his improved health to fresh air climate
and rest and he thought that he could
generalize that to treating patients.
And an 1859 he founded the world's
first sanatorium in Cy Leesha.
This was followed by Peter Date filer,
who founded in 1876 the second
major sanatorium at Falkenstein.
But despite those two examples,
the sanatorium idea didn't really take
off to become a major movement until the
1880s.
And the decisive influence was that
of the American physician who has,
uh,
through his offspring a Yale connection.
And that's Edward Livingston
Trudeau who lived from 1848.
Um,
and is well known,
the true day of name to all of you as
the great grandfather of Gary Trudeau of
Doonesbury fame.
Let me just have a couple dots.
Edward Livingston,
True Dome,
let's remember a moment about his life
and how he came to play a major role in
the sanatorium movement.
He was a physician educated at the
Columbia Medical School in New York.
His brother had tuberculosis
and he died of it.
He himself was diagnosed with
tuberculosis and the 1870s.
And,
um,
this is a story that you've
heard more than once.
He too thought that he was going to die,
but he followed medical advice and went
to an outdoor climate to take the cure.
In his case,
his preferred definition,
a destination was the Adirondack
mountains and specifically sadder,
Saranac Lake and Upper New
York state at Saranac Lake.
Which was at the time,
uh, not a town at all.
It was the wilderness and true doves spent
his time largely resting and he would
hunt from fixed positions in a canoe
on Saranac lake or behind the blind.
And as far as possible,
he stayed out doors expecting to die.
Instead,
he realized that he was starting to
feel better and he to attributed his
recovery to this fresh air and rest.
And he too, felt that this was an
experience that could be generalized.
He became increasingly interested in
the medical literature on tuberculosis,
and he read about Bramer
and his sanatorium.
But in the 1870s, there had been little
interest in the medical profession,
in the disease or in framers idea,
the 1880s because of caulks
major epic making discovery,
however,
created an entirely different and more
susceptive climate to the whole idea.
And Trudeau became an early convert
to the idea of contagion, aneurysm,
and the germ theory of disease with
specific reference to tuberculosis.
So in 1884 this is a statue of Edward
Livingston Trudeau at Saranac Lake
and he established
little red,
which was the beginning of the sanitorium.
This was in 1884 which is the beginning
then of the establishment of a small
rest cottage,
little red for the treatment
of tuberculosis patients.
This is a picture of little red,
the first building in what becomes a much
larger sanatorium and that's a picture
of the inside of the sanatorium.
There were several ideas that Trudeau
embodied in the sanatorium and the first
was not the sanatorium
was a means of treatment.
And let's look at the treatment
ideas that Trudeau had in mind.
The first was what he
called the Wilderness Cure,
the one that he had experienced himself.
That is to say that you should live
outdoors in all weather taking the cure on
cottage porches.
And so there was a document called the
rules for patients at the sanitorium at
Saranac Lake,
and it said the following,
patients are expected to lead
an outdoor life to her in Maine,
eight to 10 hours in
the open air every day.
Each patient is required to be out of
doors from 9:00 AM to 12:45 PM and again
from 2:00 PM to five 45 every day and
sleeping out is considered a no way to
affect the requirement.
So the outdoor life was compulsory.
Second was rest.
The patients at Saranac Lake,
we're to have no exercise.
A patient with a temperature of 99.5
degrees was allowed half an hour of
exercise a day and exercise included
standing up and getting dressed or walking
to the refectory for a meal
and even getting in and out
of bed was thought to be
exercise. So there was very little
that you were allowed to do.
The third thing that was part of the
sanitorium regimen at Saranac Lake,
and I'm choosing Saranac Lake because
this was the model sanitorium that really
became the ideal for an
entire international movement.
Thousands of Sanatoria.
We're founded on this model.
The third treatment idea
was a solid substantial diet
to combat the consumption,
if you like, the wasting away of
the body and to build resistance.
So in pursuit of that goal,
patients, it's sour. Now,
clay had for compulsory hardy meals a
day with milk served in between with a
strong emphasis on meat and carbohydrates.
The goal was for the patient to
consume 4,000 calories a day.
Another point about the treatment regimen
is that the sanatorium was what we
might call a total institution.
Yeah.
Unlike the old idea of taking the cure
at the sanitorium at Saranac Lake,
patients were under constant vigilance.
That was one of the reasons that you
kept them on the porches on a porch.
You were constantly in view and visitors.
We're strictly regulated.
The patient's mail was censored.
The idea being that they
should be sheltered from
distressing news and emotional
shocks.
Those were not conducive to recovery.
The roles therefore stipulated that you
weren't allowed as a patient at Saranac
Lake to discuss your disease,
even with fellow patients
at the sanatorium.
The rules also stated that there
was to be no alcohol or tobacco,
that there was to be no socializing for
more than an hour a day and there were
to be no indoor visits from
members of the opposite sex.
You also, I'm not sure if the
medical purpose of this, but, uh,
these rules were enforced by expulsion.
If you violated the rules,
you couldn't stay.
And the rules also said that
you couldn't practice profanity.
You weren't allowed to gamble.
Oh,
those were part of the cure as well.
And the next idea of this was segregation.
That is,
I'm not meaning racial segregation now.
I mean that isolation,
there were individual rooms with porches
were patients were always out of doors.
This is the polar opposite of crowded
conditions in tenements that were thought
to be the great means of spreading
the tuberculosis epidemic.
And, um, so Trudeau carried
out there was an island.
If you visit Saranac Lake,
you'll notice that there's an island which
is called rat fondly Robben Island in
the center. We're Trudeau during his, um,
I am self imposed exile for the
cure had gone hunting and so on.
But he also conducted an experiment
on rabbit island and the experiment
consistent,
I'm not sure what you think of the
robust scientific quality of it,
but it certainly convinced Edward
Livingston Trudeau himself.
He took I think 10 rabbits on to rabbit
island and five of them were allowed to
live free in a good outdoor conditions.
The other five work put
in, uh, artificial, uh,
facsimiles of tenement conditions.
That is they were
confined to insalubrious,
unsanitary crowded cardboard boxes.
And at the end of a certain period,
a Trudeau notice that the five confined
rabbits had died of tuberculosis and the
other five who were leading
the hardy outdoor life.
We're a good advertisement for a
sanitorium and the outdoor cure.
Well, let's, um,
take a little tour of the sanatorium and
we saw it started at little red in very
humble beginnings,
but then I say this was the total life.
Um,
this was the library.
As you got better,
you are allowed to do a little bit more
and you could progress to the point
where you'd be allowed the
strenuous exercise of reading
books in the Sanatorium
Library.
There was also the idea that this would
be an educational experience and you
would take back skills and knowledge
that would be essential to you after you
had been discharged from the sanatorium.
And this is a plot,
the workshop where you would learn
skills or craft that you could exercise,
remember that you might still be a
something of an invalid and it would be
important that you would have those sorts
of skills that you were capable of a
craft that you could carry out.
There was the chapel out the sanitorium.
Okay,
here is one of the cure cottages and
you'll note a proliferation of porches at
Saranac Lake. And these, uh,
are more of the buildings. Those are,
this is the central administration.
And here are,
we actually see a patient's doing what
they did most of the time at Saranac
Lake. And this is taking the cure, um,
in the horizontal position and,
uh,
being you are also educated,
to use this little, uh,
x fashion accessory,
which is your sputum
comp. In other words, uh,
your sputum was thought to be extremely
dangerous and contagious and therefore
you were not to spit on the
ground, uh, but in this little cup.
So the education of patients then in
contagiousness theory was a part of the
experience they were
issued with sputum comps,
with handkerchiefs,
spitting was strictly
forbidden at Saranac Lake,
on pain of expulsion,
and patients had severe instructions to
suppress their coughs whenever possible
and to cover their faces when they did.
So.
Saranac Lake then was not
just for its own patients.
It was also conceived of to spread
the idea of the sanitorium as a model.
And Trudeau,
and this was one of his great assets,
he was really skilled at publicity.
He became a full time agent for
his own humanitarian project.
Well,
the Saranac Lake sanitorium than was
a place of treatment and a place of
education.
It was also a place of scientific research
featuring the science of tuberculosis
at Saranac Lake Trudeau founded the
world's first laboratory devoted to the
study of tuberculosis
and caulks techniques of microscopy that
Trudeau so much admired were followed
and taught.
Medical students were taught staining
the culturing of bacteria diagnosis.
And there was a six week course for
already qualified physicians to uh,
for an internship,
if you like,
in the Saranac Lake Laboratory
and at the sanatorium.
And there were courses for nurses as
well. Well, what were the results?
We'll Trudeau himself was very optimistic
that this institution had positive
results for the health of his patients.
He argued that normally an active case
of tuberculosis was almost universally
fatal,
but Trudeau by contrast,
claimed that he achieved a recovery
rate of about 30% and so he adopted for
Saranac Lake,
a little slogan of his own,
which was cure sometimes
relief,
often,
and comfort always.
So those were parts of
the mission of the center,
Knock Lake Sanatorium.
We should also see it though,
as an instrument of public health,
based on the idea of the
isolation of the contagious,
Trudeau estimated that each
tuberculosis patient in a year,
if he or she continued to
live in an urban environment,
would on average,
in fact another 20 people.
So we could see the sanitorium
as a kind of quarantine.
And its particular idea was not.
This was to move,
remove working people and
people of modest means.
In other words,
this first American sanatorium
was a work of philanthropy
patients.
At most,
there was a sliding scale of expense and
patients were charged at most half the
cost of their stay and their treatment
and the endowment of the sanitorium
because Trudeau was very effective at
gaining approaching donors and getting
financial support for this idea and so
the endowment of the sanatorium made up
the difference.
So there was a considerable number
then of patients with no funds who were
subsidized by the institution.
Well,
this went on as well.
We can see a relationship
between tuberculosis also
and should we say economic
development in that the sanitorium
became the center piece also for the
development of a town that is Saranac
lake as a town which was based on
tuberculosis and Edward Livingston.
Trudeau and fact was also the mayor of
the town will initially those what should
remember that if you think getting into
Yale was difficult for you getting a
place at the Saranac Lake sanitorium
if you had tuberculosis was even more
difficult.
There was a rate of about 2000
people applying for every place.
Um,
and so the city of or town of Saranac
leg sprang up as a place where people
could be taken care of who weren't
admitted to the sanitorium itself.
In other words,
the town was filled with cottages,
with boarding houses,
with cure porches and the local board
of health of the town supervised and
regulated.
What went on in these cottages,
there were district nurses who gave
advice and monitored conditions and there
was a bureau of information in the town
to assist patients to find suitable
arrangements.
And then there were so called reception
college cottages for patients so ill
that they would be rejected by the
sanitorium and by the boarding houses.
Even. Um, one of the
features of the sanatorium,
it's difficult at Saranac Lake to
determine the effect because there was
considerable triage among
those who were admitted.
And one of the features of it was that
Trudeau did wish to take people into the
sanatorium whom he considered so ill
that nothing more could be done for them.
He wanted people who would actually
benefit from his cure. So in that sense,
this statistics were a little bit,
um,
massaged by the fact that the most serious
cases of tuberculosis didn't figure
in them.
Well,
the idea of the sanitorium
spread and spread rapidly.
It wasn't long before every state in the
nation had a network of Sanatoria and
some of them were specialized,
some for the indigent and
the poor that is the poor.
Some for women,
some for African Americans.
The abroad,
there were also Sanatoria,
the most famous in Switzerland
and Dave [inaudible],
you can read about it.
And Thomas Mann's the magic mountain
and that was clearly a sanatorium that
wasn't subsidized but wasn't
fat for the social elite.
So there were also Sanatoria of various
types for various social classes and um,
social groupings.
There were also distinctions within
the movement in the sanatorium idea in
England for example,
they shared the idea of the
importance of the outdoor life,
diet and surveillance,
but they differed and that they thought
that the kind of rest regimen that
Trudeau had in mind was counter productive
and that this would ruin working
people who would get used
to a life of idleness.
And so in England,
the Sanatoria instead practiced what was
called exercise and instead of the rest
treatment we have the work treatment.
And um,
those of you who are skiers,
no about the slopes are given color codes.
You're blocked diamonds, your blue
and your green for example. Well,
at the British Sanatoria,
um,
there were walks for the patients and
they were also color coded according to
difficulty and how much it was going
to make you breathe and you inmates.
Then as you got well,
you were encouraged to take
walks of progressive difficulty.
Well, in the interwar period,
there were some additional,
um, innovations in the
treatment of tuberculosis.
One was,
and this is still before the
age of antibiotics you've seen,
and one was a surgical approach and this
was practiced at Saranac Lake as well.
The idea being to extend rest,
to have real total rest of the lungs.
This was termed artificial pneumothorax
and that means that air was injected or
another gas like nitrogen into the
pleural cavity to collapse the lung or the
lungs by subjecting it or
them to external pressure.
That procedure was developed in the
1890s and came into vogue and after World
War One,
especially in this
country very invasively,
some surgeons even decided to make the
collapse permanent by removing patient's
ribs to paralyze the
diaphragm. Let me show you. Um,
this is,
uh,
a patient undergoing neumothorax
the artificial collapse of the lung.
And this is a diagram of
the neumothorax apparatus.
The remark of one surgeon was this
in a burst of surgical optimism.
He said,
physicians who have treated tuberculosis
for 2000 years and without effect,
it's time now for us surgeons to show
the way the analogy was that of the
resting of a broken limb and a cast.
Unfortunately.
However,
statistics seem to indicate that the
results were deeply disappointing and the
procedure was almost totally
abandoned by 1940 fortunately.
However, there were other weapons
in the war on tuberculosis.
One was another institution in
addition to this Sanatoria and knots,
the dispensary's
and cities to which patients returned
after discharge from hospitals and
Sanatoria.
They needed follow up care
and the dispensary's were
designed to provide that in
the community.
They also taught hygienic education,
reminding patients that even after
discharge from the Sanatoria,
they still weren't allowed to spit and
they should cover up their faces when
coughing or sneezing and they should
tell everyone in their families to do the
same.
So these were in part
health education facilities.
They also performed what we
might call social work services.
They helped recovering patients define
jobs that were suitable for their
condition.
Sometimes they provided loans or cash
grants or food to tide patients over while
they attempted to get back on their
feet after a prolonged period of being
unemployed.
There were also,
these were joined by campaigning,
voluntary associations.
And so we see a proliferation of
what we might now call angios.
And England was the National Association
for the prevention of consumption and
other forms of tuberculosis founded in
1898 and there were similar associations
in France, Germany, Belgium,
Portugal, Canada, Denmark, Sweden,
Russia, Japan, Norway, Australia.
And in our country there was the national
tuberculosis association that's now
called the American Lung Association.
And I wonder if you could guess
who its first president was. Well,
your friend Edward Livingston Trudeau,
I said he was a propagandist of genius.
The mission of these associations again
was to educate the public about the
disease,
to help teach people and how they could
protect themselves from it and also
protect those around them.
And they spent a lot of time attacking
the social construction of tuberculosis
from the first half of the 19th century.
That is the romantic idea of tuberculosis.
They stressed in
pamphlets and in lectures,
the tuberculosis was neither
romantic, newer, poetic.
One pamphlet wrote,
and I think it laid it on a bit heavy.
It said TB is of course,
common vulgar disease,
bread and foul breath in dirt and squallor
the beautiful and the rich receive it
from the unbeautiful and from the poor.
I think we're a million
miles away from La Blm.
And then he case,
the idea then was to frighten people
in order to reform their habits.
And these are associations
produced pamphlets,
they sponsored lectures,
there are traveling exhibits.
Later on there were films
and radio broadcasts,
newspaper articles,
and the propaganda blanketed
schools and hospitals,
offices and shops, factories, town halls,
billing, uh, places,
public squares, city walls,
bulletin boards at schools
and universities and
particular targets where the
habit of spitting and alcoholism.
You would've noted not too many
years ago that if you boarded a,
um,
a boss say in Paris or in Rome,
that the back of the bus would have
a sign they false to crush shed.
No spitting in French or VA Tostitos
with Todd and Italian spitting was really
something that this
campaign heavily focused on.
In addition,
there were other messages,
the outdoor life and exercise
that wasn't unrelated,
that this was the time when the scout
movement gets going to give people outdoor
experience so that
there'll be more healthy.
It's sponsored playgrounds,
it's schools and parks and cities and
urban areas and also the movement funded
research.
In the basic sciences
related to tuberculosis.
So that was part of this campaign,
the war on tuberculosis.
In addition,
there were government measures.
One was a campaign.
I said that a secondary way in which
tuberculosis was spread was through milk.
And so in this period we see the attempt
to screen herds to prevent disease,
milk and meat from reaching the market.
And it was the time when
the pasteurization of milk
took off as a practice.
Tuberculosis also by states,
municipalities and nations
was made a notifiable disease.
The pioneer here was New York City in
1897 Manchester in England followed suit
in 1899 and then there was
a cascade of other places.
We're physicians, we're obligated
to report cases to the authorities.
Now a result,
this clearly is a positive thing in
that public health depends on accurate
information and you can only get
information through statistics.
So I don't want to argue that this was
anything but positive except as many
positive measures have.
It also had a small undertone.
In other words,
this increased the fear of the disease.
People feared being reported
because they might lose their jobs,
they would lose all standing
in the marriage market.
They might be shunned by anxious friends,
neighbors and relatives.
Another idea was vaccination
and this was followed,
um, from 1925 and while eight, 19,
oh eight and particular,
but especially after 1925 with the BCG
first and vaccination with attenuated
bacteria thereafter.
Um,
not with a very successful result,
but this was part of the policy as well.
And then there was mass screening through
radiology and this tuberculosis skin
test.
Well,
how effective was the war on tuberculosis
with this set of tools used to combat
the disease? Well, interestingly,
I think one could argue that the war
on tuberculosis really gathered speed,
not at the very height of
the tuberculosis epidemic.
When there was the most suffering,
morbidity and mortality.
The decline probably began spontaneously,
somewhat earlier,
maybe reflecting the sanitarian movement
and improved urban living conditions,
improved wages and diet,
improved housing,
things that were done spontaneously and
lead to a recession of the disease by
those sorts of means.
But everyone agrees that Sanatoria and
isolation did reduce infection that
dispensary's and TB campaigning
organizations provided
those at risk with means
to protect themselves.
So they undoubtedly did have a,
an important effect on tuberculosis.
And we can see a decline in the disease
in the early decades of the 20th
century.
But the real massive decline began in
what we might call the antibiotic era from
1940 to 1980 roughly.
And here a major event,
a new magic bullet,
was devised by some and Weissman
and 1943 at Rutgers university.
That is the development of streptomycin
and the first patient to be treated with
it.
Tuberculosis patient was 1944 when a
critically ill TB patient made a full,
we're covering what seemed truly a miracle
cure and this led immediately after
world war two to a confident expectation.
And we'll see this repeated in
a number of different fields.
And with regard to a series of diseases,
the idea that worldwide eradication was
just around the corner and there was in
fact it was fueled by a constant decline
from the 1950s to the 19 mid 1980s and
tuberculosis.
And the USA,
there was a 75% decline.
There were 80,000 cases in 1954
20,000 only in 1985 and the government
confidently predicted eradication by 2010
something that you know didn't happen
and worldwide by 2025
unfortunately a troubling
problem rapidly emerged.
First there was mono therapy that is
strapped to son and soon it happened.
It was discovered that bacteria are
becoming resistant to it for a time.
The problem was overcome by
combination treatments. Two,
three medications at once
instead of monotherapy.
I saw Niacin was developed in 1952
rifampicin in 1963 but then the problem
increased with multiple drug resistant
tuberculosis and in 1985 there was a hole
and the decline.
1986 and seven a slight rise and after
1987 arise in the u s nine states,
but even more troubling a
pandemic in eastern Europe,
Southeast Asia, and sub
Saharan Africa. Indeed.
In 1993 the World Health Organization
took the step for the first time or for
claiming the TB pandemic of
world emergency and warned
that the disease might
spiral out of control.
Today there are perhaps worldwide
8 million people who develop,
AH,
give infections every year and a
million over a million people die.
Well, what are some of the factors
in this resurgent emergency?
One of course,
is poverty.
Tuberculosis thrives in the conditions
promoted by poverty and worldwide.
The nations with the
highest incidents of TB,
not by accident or those with the
lowest gross national product.
Okay.
If we look at in the United States,
we can confirm this picture and that
70% of cases in the United States occur
among racial and ethnic minorities,
40% among immigrants from abroad or
what we might call marginal groups,
intravenous drug users,
prisoners,
the homeless people in nursing homes for
the elderly or people with compromised
immune systems due to HIV aids.
And remember of course that
in an era of air travel,
our country isn't an island and can't
reduce its own burden of tuberculosis
without also dealing with
the global emergency.
There were other factors that
have fed into this upsurge.
The displacement of people due to war
or economic disaster or environmental
catastrophes.
Remember of course that refugee camps are
wonderful for propagating tuberculosis
and then there's the HIV aids
pandemic and the upsurge in malaria.
Both of those diseases
are immunosuppressive and
both act as powerful sub
straight up for the emergence
of tuberculosis. Indeed,
TB is the leading immediate cause
of death among age surfer sufferers.
Tuberculosis is the perfect
opportunistic disease.
Then there's the problem of the emergence
of drug resistance that we referred to
and that has fed the [inaudible] high
rates of incarceration feed the pen,
dammit. That's been clearly
demonstrated in Russia,
the former Soviet Union and in
our own country and in Russia,
the collapse of medical
services in eastern Europe.
And then of course there's the
availability of mass air travel.
Well,
I just wanted to close with the fact that
we're then in the midst of this world
pandemic and I wanted to say also that
there are a number of issues about
tuberculosis historically in medically
that still need to be worked out.
It's and not understood what factors
cause it to pass from the dormant state to
an active infection.
It's not known why in some people
it's a four minute disease,
but in others a slow wasting process.
It's not known why it chooses to invade
certain tissues and organs rather than
others.
It's not really clear why in the
middle decades of the 19th century it
disproportionately affected women
were as from the late 19th century.
It tended to favor men and it's not
entirely clear what were the factors that
caused this major recession of the disease
between the 1890s and 1985 although
we've dealt with quite a number of them,
spontaneous economic advance
improvement in living conditions,
government and Ngo campaigns,
the reporting of the disease,
the sanitorium movement,
and then finally the
development of antibiotics.
So that's the tuberculosis story.
From the age of consumption
down to where we are today,
which today we find ourselves
in a very problematic situation.
Condition with regard to what has been
this terrible upsurge of a disease that
defeated the confident expectation
that it would soon be eradicated.